everybody
[Applause]
bro
thank you so much
okay first question is how was breakfast
club it was good that was like a dream
for me you know so you know it was good
I enjoyed it and you would watch growing
up this was like like in Camp like every
time like in between training sessions
non-stop I'll I'll guess okay good good
I know because I was speaking to uh Tim
and he was like listen yeah yeah yeah
he's like he's like listen there's one
spot he watches this show religiously he
got to do it yeah 100 seconds right the
MMA or that yeah
it was like oh my first message of me
said I can't believe that Breakfast Club
but yeah when is it coming out
um today it came out today okay good
this morning good feedback and [ __ ] yeah
yeah all my friends
[Laughter]
so here's here you tell me if I'm right
about this but I noticed this when I
would go on the road and I would I'd be
like in Norway I'd be like Sweden it was
the only outlet for American hip-hop
globally yeah yeah so if you wanted news
you wanted this is before like obviously
now you have a bunch of like twitch
channels you've got guys like academics
are putting things out but looked at 10
years ago that's the only place yeah 100
like for everything for hip-hop and you
go to breakfast club and they're like
it's big it's not it's big it's huge so
I was like if we ever come to New York I
need to do breakfast club right now but
it's so good I enjoyed it and they were
cool with you yeah we were cool I
thought I'd be like like weird because I
normally like a bit like yeah and I was
good it was good it's different when you
when you knock people out for a living
energy
when you sued people for a living yeah
it's if you're not as scared because
you're not gonna do it but you're at you
know distance
dude I'm so stoked that you're here you
actually have the number one and number
two MMA journalist in history in the
room with you right now it's great and
it is number one
no no but he might want to stick off he
was he was 12 times what you were
12-time version of the year what was
that
the year Champion right but also one of
the most prolific not only MMA I think
just Combat Sports wow yeah yeah yeah
I'm waiting for the punch line no
there's no punch there wow everybody has
their time and then now there's there's
a new one and and now you're here with
both of us yeah
and then you have Mark and then you have
Alexis okay this is this is awesome I'm
always shocked by however it is do we
have breaking news what are we doing do
we have breaking news this guy's so good
at making content
you are so [ __ ] good at making
content
okay but I I first wanna I don't almost
listen this guy's had a very hard
what's happening yeah that's the plan is
it Cardiff and confirmed it well that's
it Christmas Holiday Stadium
[Laughter]
right yeah yeah I think for MMA you
could do more because there's no set oh
yeah
[Applause]
yeah so okay easy in the UK so you do it
for you do the third one now here's my
question yeah your whole life dream is
to have this
you get this
feel as good as you thought it would
feel yeah is there any down feeling
afterwards you've achieved the thing
you've always wanted to achieve is there
something I noticed that with myself
yeah after a big show yeah I'm so
excited and then there's like a little
bit of yeah
you go down okay what's next yes you
know okay like a big goal 16 years old
against MMA and then and I want to be
the UC world champion now God is okay
what's next and
um a coach actually missed the other day
you know my aim now to be the best of
all time you know and that can be done
you know so I'll always keep keep going
do you feel like a new confidence do you
feel like although I'll be confident in
myself I was doubted in in MMA for a
long time yeah but quite caught out of
the month I'm lucky fire and everything
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I've all been like confidence with
myself and knowing my skill set and yeah
it was sick it was now to finally
achieve it look at me now it's crazy
Look At Me Now is this new is this a new
little thing
bro all right guys we're gonna take a
break saying because it's time to get
healthy okay we're gonna get healthy the
quick and easy way with one delicious
scoop of athletic greens one ag1 right
here you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Foods or
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help start your day right okay this
special blend of ingredients supports
your gut health your nervous system your
immune system your energy recovery focus
and aging all the things literally okay
ag1 is a small micro habit with massive
benefits you're going to be sleeping
better the quality is going to be so
improved of your recovery specifically
the mental Clarity and alertness you're
going to get and it costs you less than
three dollars a day you're investing in
your health and it's cheaper than your
cold brew habit think about that right
now
it's time to reclaim your health and arm
your immune system with convenient daily
nutrition it's just one scoop in a cup
of water every day that's it no need for
a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.com flagrant again that
is athleticgreens.com flagrant to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional assurance
now let's get back to the show okay the
uh the DM's looking crazy right now or
what yeah yeah it's nuts right crazy and
like the British chicks yeah those
British like what's up with the British
like what do they call them birds or
whatever yeah yeah yeah that's how the
white words
[Laughter]
[Applause]
right now listen no you are very
respectful I know it is everything's
fine that being said yeah we gotta pass
that around yeah okay you're still quite
heavy as if I couldn't handle
by the way is that yours no no that's
not it's a loner mine was up in my house
oh it says PR in the back no way we got
to take that down yeah
so so they give you the belt because
they think that you might what get
robbed for it or some [ __ ] who's gonna
rob you nah facts nobody yeah that is
just the one to like it's hard to carry
around everywhere you're going I was
like it's quite heavy and you don't put
your suitcase in case you lose it yeah
backpacking it's a lot going on so yeah
I use a PR one just in case if I lose it
I'll lose it yeah that's not my belt you
could lose it today maybe yeah you can
keep it I mean
can you explain something to us because
uh we only know about okay there's okay
perception of of British people yeah
tough no no I mean this in Philly
there's like the two there's like the
what is it Hugh Grant guy or whatever
like that who's like kind of like soft
and whatever but generally I think
British people will kind of scrap a
little bit like if you argue at a bar
yeah
I I don't think brisbee won't fight but
when I was talking to Tim and a lot of
people said like yo there's some like
hoods out there yeah yeah yeah top boy
we're watching yeah and I'm just like
that I think Americans don't understand
because it's like wait a minute you got
Healthcare
what are y'all gangster about you know
what about yeah so what so explain that
anywhere in the world right there's like
struggles there's poverty it is yeah
like most places I think you've seen
like the Queen's brand you seem like the
the tea drinkers yeah the trumpet is
yeah yeah well I'm from
have you ever had somebody try to pull a
knife out yeah yeah I've been in three
situations uh wow yeah so nonchalant
wait a minute
you guys are beefing it and then some
guy pulls out a [ __ ] I used to bring
like a knife to school when I was young
get the [ __ ] yeah right for protection
yeah yeah you have to eat food
[Laughter]
no this is that's how they circumcise in
Birmingham they brought them to the
middle school they shot them up and then
ready to go okay so hold on so you're
bringing a knife to school because what
you're worried about on the way home or
on the way back then you could go down
everyone
without a knife you know what yeah yeah
that is birmingham's world like School
in the world 14 15 16 13 It's like a
someone
but the crimes will be for like
teenagers to be stabbing really yeah it
won't be like yeah sure it's more just
like oh close did anybody ever stab you
no no never stabbed in my life but they
tried they've been situations and how
did you how do you work around a knife
you don't pull out you know you don't
fight someone with a knife okay I care
how good you are fighting yeah you run
that one poker dead you know so it's
difficult to have like a street fight
yeah so I I suggest you running
yeah
[Laughter]
just run don't don't try and fight a man
with a with a blade yeah because even
scrapping just one little pokes anyway
you bled out and dead you know I've
actually lost like a friend I said this
is what I thought I was before like on
Father's Day last year to knife crime
and I was like Wow same thing like bled
out on the floor in front of his door
you know so it's a it is a bad pandemic
in in the UK yeah so there is like there
is a real Hood in the same way that we
have it yeah yeah yeah exactly it's like
it's a hood everywhere whatever is
tonight yeah single Mamas and no jobs in
this but it was funny when we would
watch top boy they'd be like all sharing
a gun and we'd be like oh how cute is
that
like like socialism
because I guess for us yeah you know
it's so prevalence go to the shop and
get one yeah you haven't gotten a gun
yet come on dude yeah you can borrow
mine if you want yeah
so back there if there is somebody with
a gun yeah is he like
not because it's bad man no no because
there is guns to be if you want to get
guns really it's not hard to get a gun
if you want to get a gun you know but
it's more harder for like a let's say
like a normal for School Street for
example yeah for like a random kid to go
to to buy a gun it's gonna be difficult
but if you know everyone if you know
everybody in the hood then even if
they're going to know so over here I
guess go to the shop and get one yeah 15
ID easy no mental health tricks
it's wild yeah yeah when y'all say it
it's wild yeah yeah but when we say it
we're like everybody should yeah
the police ain't got no got no guns in
the UK oh yeah dude
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
like you're not scared
he actually might be RDA remember when I
called you the Tim Duncan yeah remember
I call them the Tim Duncan MMA because
he I don't mean to hijack your story get
some respect and then end of the night
you met Tim Duncan yeah yeah because
he's in San Antonio yeah it was crazy
anyway so you manifested that I felt
like I sort of I mean honestly there was
a period where he also called something
by the way the whole world
I was on the front lines like no he was
taking bullets from these is he ever
wrong I mean that clearly nah never I
mean I had the whole dagestani Army
coming after me yeah why they all said
oh he doesn't deserve it he doesn't
deserve it why
what's going on there I'm not touching
that
yeah
but I was fighting the good fight I was
it was for years I'll say thank you to
oh wow big Arrow big Ariel the
[ __ ] build it but you know you
got it you got it
whoa no invite no invite yeah
I'm in New York
he's there he's with Israel I have a
black boyfriend yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
two minutes ago
[Laughter]
I'm done how did I compliment him and he
insulted me in the same [ __ ] time
that's how good he is
I want to know the end of the story okay
I know they're like [ __ ] like is that
put it put a gun down right I was like
yeah go now you're lucky the hands on
his gun yeah yeah
like a U-turn yeah for some reason I
don't know why yeah like jaywalking yeah
you can't walk across the street
criminal yeah anyways but you can carry
a gun yeah yeah is that put a windows
down I put like the two front ones out
in the UK which you would do that nobody
put all like the even the back corners
or the windows down and I'll just like
walk over with a gun and like this is
like a weird experience to to have yeah
in Texas in the UK
okay what do you want but yeah it's it's
wild I've never experienced that did you
get a ticket or anything no no I just
said uh what I want you doing there yeah
yeah
noses in the chat right now I mean this
is a takeover
is that for you or me though yeah I
think it I think we have a big nose time
I mean we both have big noses we get a
nose off on his show it was very funny
that's what I'm from let's go yeah
Irvington in the [ __ ] house
you're not here you gotta go I'm out you
have to go you have to go yeah where are
you going I gotta do other stuff what do
you think the busiest guy in the
business why don't you invite me to a
Shabbat
Ariel why don't you invite me to a
Shabbat ever uh you're welcome for the
views you're welcome
Leon you're the man wait for Cardiff
I'll be there let's go like them
everyone salam alaikum
peace out everyone thank you all right
the greatest let's go Hawaii
[Applause]
that's like some rum you drink rum we
also got some whiskey some tequila
um I'll go around rum yeah what's the
biggest difference between uh American
girls and UK girls
um
attractiveness
that's why UK girls
100 yeah wait wait wait wait really yeah
are they busted there no no I got some
good ones but there's a Durant to find
it is there a social difference
my mom's easier here my mom's here yeah
yeah yeah my mom's from Britain from
Great Britain yeah
[Laughter]
she's a beautiful woman but um yeah her
sisters are [ __ ] dump trucks
God bless them all okay but he said
American girls are easier oh yeah I'm
sure they give up cheeks
girls want to be though like fast enough
that's why you didn't get a job I told
you over yeah
that was kind of fire yeah it's it's
weird yeah I hate they also do that it's
so annoying yeah why don't you guys hop
on board with being on the right side of
the road grow up no like yeah
no it's like difficult like Dubai is the
same it's like they started around like
right side yeah America so it's like
it's good yeah that's all he got Dubai
we need more than two bucks
that's something to tell my wife they
have multiple wives in Dubai
I tried it but this is a western
cultural living
I'm trying to do that now yo Leo when
are we going to Jamaica though
um I'll go back and I'm going back in
December you're coming true honestly
yeah I pull up would you do a fight
there I love to but I don't know the
facility it's like a random like big
Arenas yeah yeah yeah I love to know but
I'll go back in December do a little
charger out there
um showed about tough to the people you
know give back you were born out there
yeah I was born there yeah when came to
the UK
where where were you born Kingston okay
Walton Kingston in the that's that but
that's like hood hood now they're the
Garrison which yeah are you from um it's
called Walton Walton Park Walton Park
jlp or PMP
which what which one what's your colors
what's your colors that's green right
yeah yeah yeah
um also young back then team like get
into politics yeah yeah that's right but
that [ __ ] is like more than politics
right it's like yeah you're from that
area that's your political that's right
gangs yeah people died over like
basically politics yeah you know it's
wild out there and like the Garrison's
kind of like
they police themselves right like you
got to get permission to go into certain
ones yeah when I was younger this is
like like burnt up causes like one end
of the road to our end of the road so
like no costing like Drive yeah you know
like just gonna like know someone to get
you I mean yeah it's different than the
resorts we know yeah yeah 100 yeah I
went back before like to like um the
tourist spot which is like negro it's
like the nice beaches Resort season yeah
I thought I'm friends back to like where
I grew up you know like in like zinc
it's like zinc house and yeah zinc roof
and [ __ ] yeah it's it's different my uh
I had a math teacher that was from there
and he said his school's colors yeah
were green yeah but his Garrison yeah
was
it was yellow or whatever it was so
every day yes on the way to school he's
like they picked the [ __ ] colors what
the hell they wanted to do like getting
beat up having to fight people is is not
bad no more photos like that part of it
like really that's part of it it's more
like this in-house violence yeah yeah
can you explain Vibes Cartel and why
Vibes was so like important to Jamaicans
like why why he was even so powerful
yeah
um or he is yeah yeah he's still even
now he's been in prison for like what 10
years and he's still just one of the
most popular artists like putting out
music now yeah maker you know and I
don't know I think just for some reason
everyone just click to him like UK
Native Americans did everyone just like
took to the world boss they called him
yeah yeah now he's he is and he was he
was also like a real yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah isn't that for like he's in prison
for a couple murders right I think
that's what I say a few years
um so yeah he's well he's sick he's good
yeah it's just interesting like how
important music is to the culture that a
guy like that could be this iconic
figure that has almost more more power
than like the president yeah yeah or
something yeah well in Jamaica it's like
even a good Sprinter even using a boat
that's all a good like artist like a DJ
artist like the professor Movado Movado
yeah you know so they're like
[Music]
Curious Thing I have here
um
why do you think
Jamaican culture and Jamaicans for how
few there are
are so well known globally like there's
a lot of islands that have people that
nobody knows anything about yeah you
always say like a small island is it is
so yeah yeah yeah yeah even why even
like hip-hop and everything like the
dance deserve things are crazy it's not
Jamaica right yeah I don't know I don't
know probably good food I don't know I
couldn't tell what it is the food is
yeah the vibe I don't know I don't know
what it is but there's something that
like we were even talking about this
like have you ever met a person that
said they didn't like Bob Marley sure
I've met people who are like they won't
put it on first yeah but I don't think
there's one you don't like him it goes I
hate that there are people go I don't
like country I don't like rock and roll
I don't like rap yeah there's not one
human that goes
right yeah yeah never you can't you
can't right because like what was
preaching at the time it's like crazy
yeah crazy
about mad races yeah it's different but
apart from that you just can't yeah you
gotta hate people yeah
[Laughter]
for sure but yeah Jamaica is like there
to my heart I can't wait to go back you
know it's been uh but you've four years
five years you've seen it even influence
like British culture you've seen it
influence Canadian yeah yeah like
obviously American but even like the
slang that's used yeah everything like
from the small Caribbean place you know
it's uh it's kind of it's kind of wild
wow Jamaicans is the best yeah like
growing up this girl I knew she called
me a fish a fish boy
[Laughter]
that's what calling a guy a fish means
right that he's like a good swimmer no
no
that's what she said what is it who are
you swimming with
me basically because we're a couple guys
a bunch of guys is a fish
okay so that's great that's a huge card
that's necess
[Laughter]
[Music]
I just put on the Belt immediately yeah
[Laughter]
in like a minute and then come back from
the bathroom
[Laughter]
a minute long sex
I can't say [ __ ] bro yeah first round
tapa dude that's like 100 yeah I mean
the fastest to finish it is better
better
yeah I don't think you know who you're
with
I don't get paid more time
my brother I'm so stoked I'm so stoked
you you could be here I'm so stoked for
you this is just awesome it's great to
see it's been fun uh it's just [ __ ]
too boys make it [ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
this is my last one of the tourism and
now you're good but are you staying in
town for a little bit yeah I'll go I'm
going to like a basketball game tonight
I think it's the next I think yeah the
next yeah yeah they're putting out the
Pistons okay yeah I'll be fine my first
ever games I'm excited to go yeah yeah
to go to that and watch Israel tomorrow
of course yeah yeah ahead on Monday I
gotta know who's your team are you a
Birmingham fan
um Aston Villa oh yeah yeah okay okay
wait wait wait wait because that's like
that's the area I grew up in and I was
like where's the next from what area
but there's also like Brooklyn Aston
first came from Jamaica to UK I first
went to Aston which is Aston Villa yeah
and then I moved to that editor and move
on here amazing did you have aspirations
to be a soccer player was that like was
that ever yeah as a kid as a kid
football was that the biggest thing in
Jamaica you know yeah it's the biggest
thing in the UK and in the world
football yeah see in the world told you
yeah I try to tell them to be like yeah
yeah we're learning about it yeah and
it's like NFL or football it's not it's
not the same in the UK it doesn't
translate nah over and for some reason I
do like it but for some reason it's fun
yeah it's good I don't understand it
yeah it's it's a bunch of men running
into running into each other you know
but yeah stupid sport it looks good
or something
no but the NFL athlete is I always
thought basketball was the most unique
because you have so much height and
you're still agile yeah yeah but then I
mean
Schwab was said he's like no dude I've
been with these NFL dudes and like
they're pure athleticism is [ __ ]
remarkable and I'm curious why more
don't try to do MMA training even
earlier on yeah like if you wondered
about that like are there going to be
other sports that people start to
gravitate to MMA from from MMA yeah like
like people who used to go I'm gonna be
a football star are gonna go you know
maybe let me try this UFC yeah yeah 100
that's starting to happen in the UK it's
happening now you know a lot of the kids
are going to like mixed martial arts Jiu
Jitsu box in really all right no one put
the kids Justin soda boxing no more in
in where I'm from the UK and I was like
that used to me it yeah yeah I was
growing up too it was just you just yeah
boxes boy you go straight to the box of
gym but now it's like mixed martial arts
Jiu Jitsu
it's crazy to see like the the rise of
next martial arts it's nuts and you're
at the top of it man congratulations on
everything my brother this is just
[ __ ] great thank you this is dope
thank you brother you need this back
yeah
Mark could you make sure that uh Leah or
dove Dove you're going to take Leon Leon
you're the [ __ ] man yeah I really
appreciate it so much appreciate it and
and for real hit me up while you're here
if you need anything 100 your
restaurants or anything uh well hey
enjoy the game tonight later later bro
it's gonna be good oh man oh okay there
that was sick this is awesome dude